in the ever evolving digital landscape
of 2024 where technology propels Our
Lives forward the need for cyber
Warriors has never been more pronounced
as we delve into this year the realm of
cyber security promises challenges
opportunities and a chance to make a
real difference if you have ever
pondered the path of becoming a guardian
of the digital realm 2024 might just be
the year to set your course in this era
data is not just information it's power
and with great power comes great
responsibility cyber Security
Professionals are the guardians of this
power the Vigilant Sentinels of our
Digital Society as you embark on your
journey to become a cyber security
professional you will not only be
acquiring a set of skills but also
embracing a mission safeguarding the
Digital Universe from the ever advancing
forces of cyber threats whether you are
a noce interviewed by the world of cyber
security or a seasoned IT professional
looking to specialized the road ahead
offers exciting prospects in this guide
we will navigate the intricate network
of knowledge skills and experiences
required to become a cyber security
professional in 2024 from understanding
the latest trends to mastering the
basics we will equip you with the tools
and insights to embark on a secure and
promising future in this Dynamic field
and before starting if you are an
aspiring cyber security professional
looking for online training and
certification from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice and this course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and this course requires
just a bachelor's degree with a 50%
average and no prior programming
experience and one plus year of work
experience is preferred for more details
you can use the link mentioned in the
description box and pin comment so
fasten your seat belts and let's embark
on this journey together your mission to
secure the digital world of 2024 we'll
start with who is a cyber security
professional so cyber security
professional is an expert dedicated to
safeguarding digital systems and data
they defend against cyber threats assess
risk respond to incidents and ensure
compliance with security standards
ethical hackers test system and they
play pivotal roles in securing the
digital realm through constant learning
in and evolving strategies so this is
the person or this is the cyber security
professional and now we'll see the roles
and responsibilities for the particular
category so roles and responsibilities
for a cyber security professional so the
starting is security monitoring
continuously monitor systems and
networks for potential security threats
and suspicious activities so these are
the roles and responsibilities for a
cyber security professional moving to
the next that is incident response so
cyber Security Professionals develop and
execute plans to respond to security
incidents containing and mitigating the
impact of breaches moving to the next
that is vulnerability assessment
identify and assess vulnerabilities
within systems and networks and
prioritize them for remediation and
moving to the next that is security
compliance ensure compliance with legal
and Industry specific cyber security
regulations and standards so now we'll
move to the next roles and
responsibilities so these are access
control that is Implement and manage
access controls to limit unauthorized
access to critical resources and then we
have security architecture that is
design and Implement security measures
including firewalls encryption and
intrusion detection systems and then we
have security awareness educate
employees about security best practices
to reduce human related security risk
and then we have penetration testing
conduct ethical hacking to identify and
address weaknesses in security systems
so these are some of the roles and
responsibilities of a cyber Security
Professionals and they do a very very
very pleora of roles and
responsibilities on different job roles
now we'll see the steps to become a
cyber security professional so we'll
start with the number one step that is
Educational
Foundation so establishing a strong
Educational Foundation is fundamental
for becoming a cyber security expert
obtaining a bachelor's degree in fields
like computer science or cyber security
provides Essential Knowledge and Skills
forms the basis for more specialized
cyber security training and
certification programs setting the
ground workor for a successful career in
the field so this was about the
Educational Foundation now moving to the
step two that is cyber security
courses so you can also enroll in
specialized cyber security courses and
certifications and they will help you
crack the more certifications that is
certified information system security
professional cissp certified ethical
hacker CH and certified information
security manager cism and compia
Security Plus and here we have a simply
learn postgraduate program in cyber
security from M University in
collaboration with EC Council and that
should be a right choice if you want to
crack all the certifications this course
is designed to accommodate a diverse
range of Learners and this course
requires just a bachelor's degree with
the 50% average and no programming
experience required and 1 plus year of
work experience is preferred in any
field for more details you can use the
link in the description box below now
moving to the third step that is handson
learning so Hands-On learning in cyber
security involves practical Real World
experience it includes setting up
security systems conducting penetration
test analyzing malware and responding to
simulated cyber incidents this Hands-On
approach is crucial for developing the
skills and intuition needed to address
security threats effectively so this was
the step three now moving to the step
four that is networking so networking in
the context of becoming a cyber security
expert involves building professional
relationships within the cyber security
Community it includes attending industry
events joining forums and connecting
with experienced experts these
connections provide opportunities for
knowledge sharing mentorship and staying
updated on the latest trends and threats
in the field which are essential for
career growth and expertise so now
moving to the step
five that is ethical hacking skills
ethical hackers also known as Whitehead
hackers specialize in Legally and
proactively identifying vulnerabilities
and weaknesses in systems and networks
they use their skills to simulate cyber
attacks uncover security flows and
provide recommendations to strengthen
defenses ethical hacking is essential
for maintaining robust cyber security by
preventing malicious experts so this was
about the step five now moving to the
step six that is stain form continuously
update your knowledge by following cyber
security blogs attending webinars and
subscribing to Industry Publications
staying informed about the latest
threats vulnerabilities and security
Trends is essential in the ever evolving
field of cyber security enabling you to
adapt and protect against emerging risk
so now moving to the step seven
that is internships and entry-level jobs
internships and entry-level jobs in
cyber security provides invaluable Real
World Experience they offer Hands-On
exposure to security tools processes and
best practices these positions allow
individuals to apply their knowledge
work alongside experienced professionals
and develop practical skills setting the
foundation for a cyber security
successful career and now moving to the
next step that is Step eight and that is
specialized domain specializing in cyber
security involves focusing on a specific
area within the field such as Network
Security application security or
incident response by deepening your
expertise in a particular domain you
become better equipped to address
specialized threats and challenges
making you a valuable asset in the cyber
security landscape now moving to the
step nine that is
certifications certifications are vital
in the cyber security Journey they
validate your expertise and open career
opportunities start with foundational
certifications like coma Security Plus
and progress to Advanced ones such as
cissp or cism these credentials showcase
your knowledge and commitment to
potential employers making you a more
attractive candidate for cyber security
roles now I'll just tell you about the
list of popular cyber security
certifications number one is cissp that
is certified information security system
security professional and this
demonstrates expertise in information
security and is highly recognized
globally then we have certified ethical
hacker that focuses on ethical hacking
and penetration testing preparing
professionals to identify and address
vulnerabilities then we have cism
certified information security manager
that validates skills in managing and
governing an Enterprise information
security program and then we have cisa
certified information systems audito
that focuses on audit control and
Assurance skills for information systems
and then we have coma Security Plus an
entry level certification covering
foundational security skills and
knowledge and then we have ccsp
certified Cloud security professional
that specializes in Cloud security
demonstrating expertise in securing
Cloud environments and then we have
cissp issap that is certified
information security technician that
concentrates on architecture emphasiz
izing risk management and governance and
then we have cism certified information
security manager that validates skills
in managing and governing and Enterprise
information security program and then we
have ccsp certified Cloud security
professional that specializes in Cloud
security demonstrating expertise in
security Cloud environments and we have
a list of all the certified cyber
security certifications but these are
the top of the main certifications which
you can pursue now moving to job roles
and average salary so the first job role
we have is information security manager
and the average salary for this
particular role is
$150,000 in us and for in India that is
11 lakhs perom and then we have the next
job role that is cyber security engineer
and the average salary for this role in
US is
$145,000 per year and in India that is
13 lakhs perom and then we have the next
role that is application security
engineer and for this role the average
salary in US is
$120,000 and in India that is 10 lakhs
perom and then we have network security
engineer and the average salary for this
role is
$56,000 in us and in India that is 8
lakhs perom and then we have cyber
security analyst and for this role the
average salary in US is
$15,000 per anom and in India that is 7
Le per an and now moving to the
companies hiring cyber security
professionals so the companies are
Amazon asenta Google Apple and Intel so
these are the top most companies that
hire cyber Security Professionals and
every company needs cyber Security
Professionals to safeguard their systems
and to defend the customers identities
or their credentials and this was all
about for this tutorial hope you guys
found it informative and helpful if you
if you are an aspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more we have
simply learned Advanced executive
program in cyber security in
collaboration with npci and that should
be your right choice with this program
you can transform your career in 6
months for India specific region only
this course provides a high engagement
learning experience with real world
applications and is designed for
individuals who want to start a new and
more fulfilling career and if you like
this session then like share and
subscribe if you have any questions then
you can drop them in the comment section
below thanks for watching and stay tuned
for more from Simply loan staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn ner up and get certified
click
here